so how do you win people over well this
is the big question that skeptics
atheist seculars have you know it's like
okay we have a position here you know we
have a set of tenets and beliefs that we
believe in science and reason and
critical thinking and this is our
position on all these different issues
now how do I convince you of this okay
if you attack somebody you know pretty
aggressively and and you don't treat
them with respect the wall goes up you
know the cognitive dissonance kicks in
you know these are my beliefs and you're
telling me I'm wrong okay whoa okay I'm
gonna double down if I want to sell you
a vacuum cleaner or whatever what's the
best thing I should do or you know like
I want you to take my survey so I mail
you the survey and I put a dollar in
there yeah why do they do that because
that's a tried and trued tested method
that of reciprocity it's like oh I got
this dollar and you put it in your
wallet whoo I got a dollar
all right I better fill out the form I
feel obligated because they gave me
something I should give them something
back it's a basic principle of human
psychology I will give you respect if
you if you hear me out and you give me
respect if I hear you out and and there
you can at least plant a seed of doubt
you know it's rare that anybody's gonna
you know listen to the arguments about
carbon dioxide or the ice core data or
whatever and go yeah yeah you know that
climate skepticism stuff is a lot of
nonsense
I changed my mind right now that almost
never happens what you want to do is
just put a few things in there and then
maybe the next day or a month later you
know they're there thinking about it and
the next time they're reading the New
York Times or The Wall Street Journal or
they're listening to talk radio to
thinking oh yeah yeah yeah I remember
Shermer was saying something about and
you know they just start thinking about
it they changed their way of thinking
and that begins to shift the paradigm a
little bit I have had a range of beliefs
in my life I used to be a Christian for
example I used to be a climate skeptic I
was against gun control so on any of
these issues I can say you know I I used
to be a Christian too you were oh yeah I
totally accepted Jesus into my heart as
my Savior God so loved the world he gave
His only forgotten begotten Son John
3:16 I repeated that Wow what happened I
changed my line how come you change your
mind well you know I started thinking
about
and that and the evidence and the
problem of evil the problem of evil oh
yeah yeah it's a by just saying well
here's what I think in a respectful way
yeah you you believe what you want I
understand I used to believe that too
but if you do it in an insulting way
like you know I used to be a child too
but I grew up walls going up you know
you just insulted me fan well screw you
too
fan end of conversation